SAURABH GUPTA: Good afternoon,
and welcome to everyone in
this room and watching on the
Livestream and YouTube.
My name is Saurabh Gupta.
I'm Product Manager of
Google Apps Script.
JONATHAN RASCHER: I'm
Jonathan Rascher.
I'm a software engineer
at Google Apps Script.
SAURABH GUPTA: And today, we are
going to show you how you
can extend Google Docs
with Apps Script.
So with a show of hands, how
many of you have heard of
Google Docs or used
Google Docs?
Almost all of you.
I figured that much.
But for those of you who haven't
or those of you who
are watching on the Livestream,
Google Docs is a
word processing app
in Google Drive.
Using Google Docs, you can
create and share documents
across devices--
in your browser, on your iPhone
or Android phone.
And yes, it works even when
you are not connected.
It's really awesome.
But you know what is
even more awesome?
Starting this week,
you can use Apps
Script in Google Docs.
That's awesome.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
And for those of you who do not
know what Apps Script is,
well, Apps Script is
the JavaScript
engine in the cloud.
And it lets you integrate and
automate and make the most out
of Google Apps.
So you might ask, well, that's
all great and good and yeah,
you can use the Apps Script in
Google Docs, but what does
that really mean?
So just to elaborate on that,
let me share a simple story.
And this happened a few months
ago, and Jonathan will
remember this.
Jonathan and I were hanging out
with our friend, Bob, in a
bistro a few months ago.
And Bob was talking about
awesome research that he's
doing and this great research
paper that he's writing.
And we were pretty excited
because we know Bob is a
Google Docs user.
So we were super excited
about that.
And he was going on and
on about his research.
But he had a slight problem.
He said, well, he is referring
to a ton of sources--
books, journals, articles,
you name it.
And he's having a hard
time keeping up.
And what's even more worrying
for him was that he wanted to
make sure that he's citing all
these sources, he's giving
credit where credit is due.
So this was a genuine
problem for him.
So you know what
happened next?
Well, something that usually
happens when you put a user,
an engineer, and a product
manager on the table.
A napkin comes out, and people
start scribbling stuff.
And that's what we
exactly did.
And we drew something and said,
hey Bob, you need a
bibliography management
app in Google Docs.
And Bob said, yeah, I want to be
able to add sources to it--
all of those sources
that you just saw.
Not just that, I want to be able
to cite those sources in
my research paper.
And, at the end of it, I want to
have a well-formatted, good
looking bibliography in
my research paper.
So he said, yes, exactly.
This a great use case.
And right after the dinner,
Jonathan and I went back to
the office and said, hey, we've
got to build our friend
Bob this app.
And that's what we
exactly did.
And you know what we built?
We built an app called Bibstro
using Google Apps Script.
And then you will ask,
why Bibstro?
Well, it's obvious.
In the moment of sobriety, we
were sitting in a bistro, and
we thought about
bibliographies, so why not Bibstro?
But the important thing here
is that this app is built
using Google Apps Script.
And what we are going to show
you here in the next two
minutes is a demo of Bibstro.
And the point of the demo
is that you can
build your own app.
And we hope to give you some
insights into how you can
build your own app
in Google Docs.
So let's get to the demo.
This is Google Docs, and this
is Bob's research paper.
And as you can see, on the Menu
left of Help, is a menu
item called Bibstro.
So the first thing that
Bob needs to do is
configure this app.
And so he clicks on Bibstro,
and he clicks on Settings.
And you can see there
is a submenu, and
he clicks on Configure.
And up comes a form, and he
chooses a citation format, and
he configures the app.
That's pretty straightforward.
The next thing, if you remember
from the napkin that
I was talking about, was he
needs to add sources--
all of those list of papers
and journals and
all of those articles.
So he clicks on Bibstro, clicks
on Add Source, and up
comes another form.
And you can see how
well-formatted and good
looking UI it is.
And he starts adding all of
these sources in this app.
And he collects a list of
sources, and a bibliography
gets generated for it.
So he adds a source, and the
next thing he does is he
scrolls all the way to the
bottom of the document and
sees that, hey, here's
this bibliography--
well-formatted according to the
standard that he chose,
and it's right there.
So that's awesome.
That's cool.
So he gets a bibliography.
He is able to add sources.
The next thing he wants to do is
be able to cite the source.
So he scrolls up in his
document, locates the cursor
wherever he wants to cite the
source, then clicks on the
menu item Bibstro and clicks
on Add Inline Citation.
And now he can choose from any
of the source and cite that
source right in the document.
So this is awesome, and
you can see the
source is now cited.
So we met all of Bob's
requirements and built this
app using Google Apps Script.
But Bob is our friend, and we
wanted to throw in a little
bit of extra.
So the extra that we wanted to
throw in was, hey, what if Bob
wants to see where a particular
source is
cited in the doc?
So we built a capability
called Manage Sources.
So Bob clicks on, again, Bibstro
and says, OK, I want
to manage a source.
And up comes on the right side
a panel which shows a list of
all of Bob's sources.
And here, Bob can just say,
OK, I want to highlight a
particular source.
And you can see a source
is highlighted.
And he can remove the source
if he wants and do all of
these kinds of interesting
things.
But the one last thing that is
pretty interesting is that he
can scroll all the way to the
bottom of his bibliography and
say he just plays
around with it.
Say he corrupts it
or something.
Then he can just click on
Refresh, and a bibliography
gets refreshed.
So that's a very simple demo of
a type of app you can build
in Google Docs using
Apps Script.
And we want to make sure that
yes, your app is also as
awesome as this one using
Google Apps Script.
So let's get started.
How do you build an
app like that?
Or rather, how did
we build Bibstro?
So there are four steps
in building Bibstro.
The first step is that you
want to be able to create
scripts using the Script
Editor in Google Docs.
So this is Google Docs.
You can see the Tools
menu is expanded.
And in the Tools menu,
you will see
two new menu options--
the Script Editor and
the Script Manager.
Using the Script Editor, you
can create container-bound
scripts to Google Docs.
And you can learn a lot about
container-bound scripts on our
developer documentation.
But the crux of it is that these
scripts live and die
with the document.
So this is the starting point.
You want to be able to create
scripts in Document.
What's next?
The second thing is you want
to identify how you want to
plug your app into the
UI of Google Docs.
So again, this is Google Docs.
And anything that you want to
do with Google Docs always
starts with this class
called DocumentApp.
If there is one thing that I
want you to take away from
this session, it's this-- that
DocumentApp is your starting
point in building apps
for Google Docs.
So this is Google Docs.
And what you see highlighted
is the menu, or the UI.
And it's very simple.
If you want to get a handle to
the UI of Google Docs, just
call DocumentApp.getUi.
It's that simple.
And then I'm going to show you
some amazing things that you
can do with the UI.
So first up is inserting a menu,
and it's pretty simple.
As you can see on the code
on the right, that
DocumentApp.getUi.createMenu,
and you can create a top level
menu, then add items to it.
And you can even add
submenus and so on.
But the idea is that
DocumentApp.getUi gives you a
handle to the different UI
aspects of Google Docs.
So adding a menu is great.
What's next?
Showing your app in a sidebar.
Now, if your app shows up in
sidebar, that's great, because
what users get with this is the
opportunity to use your
app while they're working with
the document so it does not
interrupt the flow
of the user.
So this is a natural place where
your app shows and is
very useful.
And again, using
DocumentApp.getUi.showSidebar.
You can also surface your
app in a dialog.
That interrupts the flow of the
user, but it's perfect for
forms and other things.
Again, using
DocumentApp.getUi.showDialog.
It's quite similar to what
you saw yesterday
in the Forms session.
This was pretty similar where
it was FormsApp.getUi and
showDialog and all of that.
So there's a consistent theme
around it as to how you get to
the UI of Docs.
This example here is a little
bit involved, but it shows you
how you can serve your
app in a dialog.
So say for instance, if you had
a configdialog.html or an
HTML file in your script project
and that's the app
that you wanted to show in a
dialog, then you can very
easily, using HTML service of
Apps Script, create an HTML
output object and just
plug that in, in Show
Dialog, and that's it.
So you create an HTML output
object using HTML service, and
just paste that in Show
Dialog, and your
app as up and about.
So we talked about four steps,
and we talked just two steps.
You can create scripts using
the Script Editor.
You can extend the UI of Google
Docs, plug into the UI.
The third thing you want to do
is you want to wire your app
into the Google Docs UI.
So the idea is your app should
fire up somehow.
Or another way of asking this
is, what is the Main
equivalent, Main function,
as you have in Java or C?
What is the Main here?
So let's look at how your
app gets loaded up.
So when a user opens a document,
Apps Script looks in
your code and looks for a
function called onOpen.
So onOpen is sort of that
equivalent of Main.
And once Apps Script finds
onOpen, it executes onOpen.
So a typical use of onOpen
is to insert menus.
Because you want to be able to
extend the UI once the user
opens the document.
And then, by clicking on menu
items, you want the user to
start using the app.
So this is a natural flow.
A document is opened, onOpen is
called, onOpen inserts menu
items, and then user can click
on menu item and the
corresponding function
will be invoked.
So that's simple,
straightforward.
So we covered three steps--
create scripts using the Script
Editor, extending the
UI of Google Docs, responding
to events.
Jonathan now is going to cover
how you can work with the
document and modify
the documents.
Jonathan?
JONATHAN RASCHER: Yes.
Thank you, Saurabh.
So Saurabh began the talk
with our friend Bob.
And he was a Google Docs user,
like Saurabh and I, like, I
think, almost all of
you, it seems like.
And he had this problem
with Google Docs.
He wanted an ability to manage
bibliographies in Docs.
And so we built him an app for
that called Bibstro using this
new Apps Script
[? configuration. ?]
And so Saurabh just covered
the first three
steps we used for this.
So we created some scripts.
We extended the Google Docs UI
with custom UI elements.
And we can respond to events
from those UI elements for
things like menu clicks or
button clicks, for example.
So that brings us to
the fourth point.
And this point is completely
specific to DocumentApp.
If any of you saw, for example,
the talk some of our
colleagues gave yesterday about
the integration with
Google Apps Script and Google
Forms, you'll see that these
first three steps are very
similar in Forms as in Docs or
in Spreadsheets.
But this fourth step is specific
to Google Docs.
So what we need to learn is, how
is the document exposed to
Apps Script?
So when we want to do something
in Bibstro, like
maintain this live updating
bibliography at the end of the
document, how do we actually
insert, and read, write, and
modify the text in
the document?
And there's a couple of
different ways that we can
work with the Google Docs
document from Apps Script,
which I'm calling
document models.
The first of those is as
a tree of elements.
So if you've ever done work
with, say, HTML or XML, the
Document Object Model or the
DOM, then this should be
somewhat familiar to you.
It's a tree-structured
document,
much like a web page.
Let's take a look at what
this looks like.
So on the left, you can see
we have a document.
This one's pretty simple.
It's got a couple
of paragraphs.
There's a bulleted list.
There's a table and then at
the bottom of the page,
there's a page footer.
So this is all exposed to Apps
Script as Document, the
Document class.
And we get this in Apps
Script code by saying
DocumentApp.getActiveDocument.
And we'll see some
code samples for
this in just a minute.
So this is sort of the
equivalent of the root element
of, say, a web page,
the HTML element.
And like the HTML element in a
web page, it's subdivided up
into sections.
So we can see we have a body
section at the top that's
highlighted.
And then there's
a little break.
And then down at the bottom,
we have a footer section.
A page could also have, for
example, a header section.
Or it could have a
footnote section
for numbered footnotes.
And these are all optional.
But any page is going to have
a body, a document body.
If we take a look now inside the
body, you can see that it
contains elements--
again, like in a web page-- it
contains elements for things
like paragraphs, list items,
tables, and so forth.
These are kind of
the equivalent
of block level elements.
And they, in turn, are further
subdivided up into other
elements, into inline
elements.
For example, if we take a look
at this first paragraph here,
this first paragraph just
has some text in it.
But in the middle of that
run of text, the text is
interrupted by an image.
So how is this exposed
to Apps Script?
If you take a look now, you can
see that this paragraph
element has three
child elements.
There's a text element, and
that represents the run of
text up to but not including
the image.
And then in the middle,
there's an
inline image element.
And that lets Apps Script access
properties of the image
like the binary contents of the
image or the MIME types,
so whether it's a PNG,
or a JPEG, or a GIF,
or what have you.
And then after that, there's
another text element.
And this next text element just
contains all of the text
in the paragraph from the inline
image up until the end
of the paragraph.
And again, if you've ever done
work with HTML, it should be
very similar to what you've
done with web pages.
Some of the element names are
little bit different, but the
basic idea is the same.
And in Apps Script, when we work
with the document that
the user sees on screen, what
we're actually doing when we
use this tree-based document
model is saying, OK, we're
going to take a look at
the document tree.
And we're going to take a look
just at specific elements or
specific nodes in the document
tree and do things like insert
elements or delete them,
change style
properties, and so forth.
This has all been kind of
an abstract overview.
So now let's see a
concrete example.
So recall from Bibstro, we had
this functionality where
Bibstro maintained, again,
the bibliography at
the end of the document.
And you saw that the first thing
Saurabh did in his demo,
he configured Bibstro to
pick a citation format.
So he picked MLA format.
But let's say you have a paper,
and you want to change
it for another journal.
For example, you want
to change it to a
new citation format.
So you go into Configure.
You change from MLA format to
APA format, for example.
So what we want Bibstro
to do--
and what it, in fact, does--
is at that point updates the
bibliography, replaces the
existing sources, the existing
formatted references, with new
references in the new citation
format that you selected.
So now, let's take
a look at how we
actually do that in Bibstro.
Step one is we define the
bibliography in the document.
We need to find the elements
in this document tree that
represent the contents of the
bibliography that the user
sees in their Document View.
And you can see at the top,
I've put this little blue
rectangle around this element
that says "Works Cited."
That's what we're going to call
the Title Paragraph at
the top of the bibliography.
And it's part of the MLA
citation format.
It's an indicator to somebody
reading an article or an essay
or what have you that OK,
the paper is done now.
This is where the bibliography
starts.
But it can also be an indicator
to Apps Script
programmatically of that
exact same thing.
That this is where, in the
document tree, the
bibliography begins.
So step one--
there's going to be three
steps total--
step one here is to find
that paragraph.
So here we have some code
to do just that.
So we start out with
documentApp.getActiveDocument,
and we say getBody to get that
body section-- the main
contents of the document
between
any headers or footers.
And then we just do this while
loop, and we'd use the
findElement call on
the document body.
So what the findElement call
does is it takes two
parameters.
It takes the type of element
we want to find.
In this case, we say that's
just a paragraph.
So what we're saying actually
here is, loop over all the
paragraphs in the
document body.
And then it also takes this
search result object.
And at each iteration of the
loop, the search result object
is going to be populated with
the elements that we're
looking at right now.
And so we take that element,
that paragraph that we're
looking at, and we get its
text using Edit as Text.
And we compare that to
this known string,
which is Works Cited.
And when we find this paragraph
whose text is equal
to Works Cited, we know that
we've completed step one here.
We found the title paragraph,
and hence, we found the rest
of the bibliography in the
document, which brings us to
this point.
And so because the user wanted
to change their citation
format, the easiest way to do
this is just completely wipe
out the contents of the
bibliography and then just
reinsert new bibliography entry
paragraphs using the new
citation format.
So let's take a look
at how we do this.
We start out with the title
paragraph that we had
previously.
And now we do another
while loop.
But this time, we're not
finding elements.
We're looking at the next
sibling elements.
Again, if you worked with the
document tree in HTML--
with JQuery, for example--
this should be somewhat
familiar.
And if not, basically, a sibling
element is just the
element in the document that
comes immediately after the
bibliography title.
So we do this, and now we want
to remove that paragraph, that
first bibliography entry after
the title from the document.
So how do we do this?
It's a two step process.
So we take the title paragraph,
we get the
paragraph after it.
And we take this bibliography
entry
paragraph and we call Clear.
What Clear does is it says,
take the contents of this
paragraph, any text or any other
elements inside of it,
and just wipe them out
of the document.
So at this point, we have the
title paragraph followed by an
empty paragraph where the
first bibliography
entry used to be.
But we don't even want
an empty paragraph.
We don't want to have any
paragraph at all left.
So what we do is
we call Merge.
Merge is kind of an interesting
operation, I think.
It doesn't really map up cleanly
to the HTML document
object model or to an XML
document operation.
What Merge is going to do is
it's going to say, take this
second paragraph, this
bibliography entry paragraph--
now it's empty because
we just cleared it--
and collapse this empty
paragraph into the
paragraph before it.
So now, after we call Merge, the
end result is we used to
have two paragraphs, now
we just have one.
And its contents is just the
contents of the title
paragraph, because we cleared
the contents of the old
bibliography entry before
we called Merge.
And so then we just
do this in a loop.
And each iteration of the loop
uses this two step process to
remove one of the biography
entries from the document.
And we do this until we've
removed all of those
bibliography entries after the
title paragraph, which brings
us to this point.
So at this point, we have
the Works Cited
paragraph at the top.
And it's sitting there all by
its lonesome self, and it's
kind of sad, because all of
its friends are gone.
So now what we want to do is
insert some new paragraphs
after it with the same
bibliography data from the
data store, but with the
new citation formats.
The text in the document will
be different even though it
represents the same sources.
And we do this as follows.
This time, instead of removing
elements from the document, we
want to insert elements into
the document tree.
So we take the title
paragraph--
once again, this is kind of our
anchor or our reference
point that tells us where in
the document tree does the
structured bibliography start?
And we take that title paragraph
and we get its
parent element.
So in this case, that'll
most likely be the
document's body element.
But it makes the code a little
bit more general to speak of
it just as a parent.
And so we take this parent
element, and we use it to get
the child index of the
title paragraph.
That is to say, we use it to get
a number that represents
OK, which element, how many
elements into the parent is
this title paragraph?
And then we load some source
data for the bibliography
references.
We load that from
a data store.
And for each source, we have
some code somewhere to format
that according to the
citation format that
the user has selected.
And so we do that.
And we have this
formatted text.
And now we need to actually
put it into the document.
And this is really simple.
We take the parent element that
we found a minute ago,
and we just say, Insert
Paragraph.
That takes two things.
First of all, it takes a child
index or an insertion point.
And to get this, we just use
the insertion point that we
computed previously, by getting
the child index of the
title paragraph and adding
one to that.
And then this also takes a
string, which, in this case,
is just the formatted contents
of this new paragraph of the
bibliography entry.
So we make this Insert
Paragraph call.
And after we do that, we've
now inserted a new
bibliography entry paragraph
after the title paragraph.
And then we can do things like
set margins, set styles, or
whatever we want to do
on this new paragraph
that we've just inserted.
And that's about it.
We do this in a loop, over and
over again for each source.
And at the end of this loop and
at the end of this three
step process, we've now removed
the old bibliography
entries from the document and
replaced them with new entries
using the new, up-to-date
citation format.
And so that's pretty much how
we use the document tree in
Apps Script to work
with the document.
And it's great.
It's a little bit involved,
but it's really not that
complicated.
But it does involve a
good bit of code.
You can see I had to split
this over three slides.
So for cases where we don't
actually care about the
elements of the document, about
the tree structure, it
seems like it would be nice if
we had some way to work with
the document just as rich text,
ignoring intricacies
like different elements.
It turns out that we also can
look at the document as this.
The second document model is a
long string of formatted text,
of rich text, ignoring anything
like non-text
elements, like sections
and so forth.
And you recall from Bibstro,
we had this functionality
where we have this sidebar,
which I totally love.
We have this sidebar, and the
user can pick a source in the
bibliography in the sidebar.
And they can click the
Highlight button.
And then that source, all the
citations that reference that
source, will be highlighted in
the document by setting their
background to yellow.
So how do we do this?
Do we need to worry about
element trees and all of this
for something like this
that's strictly
a text-based approach?
I saw somebody shake their head,
and I love that, because
no, we don't.
So we have
DocumentApp.getActiveDocument
and getBody, and that's
the same as before.
But now the technique we're
using here starts
to diverge a bit.
So now we say Edit as Text.
You might recall we did this
a minute ago on a single
paragraph to get just the
text of a paragraph.
But we can also do this on the
entire document body, and this
is going to give us back a text
element that contains
just the textual contents of the
paragraph with things like
inline images or inline drawings
just left out.
So they're still left
in the document.
They won't be removed from the
document that the user sees.
But they're removed from the
model of the document, or the
view of the document, that's
exposed to Apps Script.
And then we can use normal
string operations in
JavaScript.
For example, here we have a
regular expression in the
middle of the slide.
And that matches parenthesized
substrings in the
document, or citations.
And you can tell it's a regular
expression because it
is horrendously ugly
and it's just an
abomination to look at.
But that's just standard
JavaScript.
And so we do a JavaScript
regular
expression match in a loop.
And we loop over all the
citations in the string
contents of the document body.
And for each of those citations,
what we do is we
say, OK, we have some
logic to find out.
Does it go with the source that
we're trying to highlight?
And if it does, we want to set
the background color for that
substring in the document
body to yellow.
So we use this body text element
that we got in the
first step, and we say
body text element
set background color.
And that takes just
three things.
It takes the first two
parameters as indices, so a
start index and an end index.
And we compute these just
using the normal regular
expression indices we got from
the RegEx match, because these
indices, they're just character
text indices.
They ignore things like
element child
positions and so forth.
And then finally, we just
pass in a color.
So that's the hexidecimal
color code for yellow.
And that's about it.
So this Edit as Text based
approach, you can see it's
very different than
the document tree.
It is not quite as powerful.
The document tree can do
anything to the document,
whereas this can only perform
text and formatting
operations.
But for text and formatting
operations like highlighting
citations in an essay, in fact,
this lets you do the
same thing as you can do with
the tree-based approach, but
in much less code.
And, in my opinion, in code
that's much easier to read,
regular expressions
notwithstanding.
So that's about it.
We have these two models
of the document.
We can work with it either as a
tree, like a web page, or as
a long string of rich text with
formatting attributes
applied to each character
in that string.
There's one other model of
working with the document.
This is not launched yet, but
it's going to be coming out in
the next couple of weeks after
I/O. And you saw Saurabh
actually hinted at
it in his demo.
And that is, we're going to give
you an API to work with
cursor and selection
in the document.
So when the user positions their
cursor in some text or
next to an image, or selects a
range of text or a table or
whatever you might have, we're
going to give you the ability
to determine where is the
cursor, or what is the
selection, and to operate on
the cursor or selection by
doing things like inserting
text at the cursor.
So recall from the Bibstro demo
that Saurabh showed, we
have this menu, and we let the
user put their cursor after a
sentence or phrase they
want to cite.
And the user says,
Insert Citation.
And we show them a dialog,
and they pick a source.
And then that source appears
in the document right after
their cursor.
So this is working today.
We're finalizing the API for
launch to give you something
that reduces complexity in
a bunch of edge cases.
There are surprisingly
many edge
cases in document selection.
It's kind of amazing.
So there you go.
That's about it.
We have these four steps that
we use to build this app
called Bibstro, to build
a bibliography
app in Google Docs.
So we created some scripts using
the Script Editor, using
the new Google Docs integration
that we just
launched a couple days ago.
And we extended the Google Docs
UI to add things like
custom menus and dialogs, and
my personal favorite, custom
sidebars, because who doesn't
love a sidebar?
And then we also have the
ability to respond to events,
just like in any other
event-driven programming framework.
And those events can do things,
they can do operations
on the document on behalf of the
user, which is what makes
this all work together and
lets us build apps that
automate Google Docs--
apps like Bibstro or apps like
whatever you all want to do
any use case, document workflow,
whatever you want in
Google Docs.
I'm excited to see what
you all are going
to build with this.
I kind of hope you give it a
better name than Bibstro,
because that's just bad.
So we have this.
That's about it for the talk.
We have some links here
to our documentation.
And also, I know I brushed over
the code samples kind of
quickly to get in a couple
of examples.
So we're going to be posting
all of the code for this
Bibstro sample app online in a
couple of weeks after I/O. So
keep your eye on, say, the
Google Apps Developer Blog and
the Apps Script pages on
developers.google.com.
So I think that's about it.
Thank you all for watching.
And, at this point, if you have
any questions, looks like
there's a couple of mics in
the middle of the room.
So come up and talk
into the mic.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Hi Is this available
only for Docs, or available
also for the Spreadsheets
and the [INAUDIBLE]?
SAURABH GUPTA: Today, you
can use scripts in
Spreadsheets and cite.
In yesterday's session, we
announced in Forms as well and
now in Documents.
Yes, please.
AUDIENCE: The adding of the
menus is different on
Spreadsheets, right?
So in Spreadsheets,
you say, Add Menu.
And so when are you going
to integrate the same
functionality, the new UI
service to add the sidebars?
What's the timeline for that
coming on Spreadsheets?
SAURABH GUPTA: It will
happen pretty soon,
and this will converge.
As you saw in Forms and Docs,
we are creating a concept of
DocumentApp.getUi.
So if you can get handle to the
UI, you'll see something
similar in Spreadsheets
as well.
JONATHAN RASCHER: Right, and
this will include the full
range of what we talked
about today.
So things like, for example,
the sidebar that you can't
show today in Spreadsheets.
That sidebar that exists now in
DocumentApp and in FormApp
will be coming to SpreadsheetApp
in the next
couple of weeks.
AUDIENCE: Just on the new
cursor-based location, would
we get a right click menu?
SAURABH GUPTA: We have not
planned for it, but let's talk
about it at the Office Hours.
AUDIENCE: OK, thanks.
SAURABH GUPTA: Yes, please?
AUDIENCE: I've got a question
about deployment.
So is it something I can create
only inside my own
document, or is it something I
can create once and deploy it
to all the users in my domain?
SAURABH GUPTA: So what you're
asking is really how you
distribute a script that can
be inserted into all the
documents across a number
of users and stuff.
So we're working on that.
And do watch the Google Apps
Developers Blog for
more news on that.
It's not there yet,
but coming soon.
AUDIENCE: OK, thanks.
SAURABH GUPTA: Yes, please.
AUDIENCE: I wanted to ask about
if you've considered
cross-document integration.
So for example, if I have a
spreadsheet I want to use as a
data source to fill a Doc with
the citations, for example, or
if I want to hit an external
data source, such as I've got
a Cloud SQL database running and
I want to be able to pull
content from that into a report,
for example, and then
drive that into a Doc.
JONATHAN RASCHER: So that is
an excellent question.
And I think the answer is, we
don't have anything pre-built
to do this, but I think we give
you all the tools you'd
need to do that.
For example, we have
services called
SpreadsheetApp and DriveApp.
So what you could do--
I can't think of any
reason not to--
is you could have a sidebar in
Google Docs, or a dialog, that
uses the DriveApp service to let
the user pick a file from
their Google Drive, to pick a
spreadsheet, and then use the
SpreadsheetApp to take that
spreadsheet, read it in data
format, and populate it
into the document.
So there's nothing prefabricated
to do this, but
I believe we have all
the tools for
you to do that today.
SAURABH GUPTA: Yes, please?
One more question.
AUDIENCE: Are you planning
on extending the document
permissions to, for example,
keep allowance for editing
document but not editing the
scripts inside of documents?
SAURABH GUPTA: I'm sorry.
I did not understand
your question.
AUDIENCE: So when you give
somebody a permission
currently to edit your document,
you automatically
give them the permission to edit
scripts in the document.
Are you planning on having a
separate permission to allow
editing the document, but not
allowing editing the scripts?
SAURABH GUPTA: That's an
interesting question, and we
debated this a lot.
When you create scripts,
they're
a part of the document.
They are inherent in the
sharing model from the
document itself.
So Edit privileges on the
document mean Edit privileges
on the script.
However, as a developer, what
you can do is you can use
libraries and then sort of
abstract that out where you're
using a library and not giving
editor permissions on the
library, just a view.
And so you can abstract
some of that out.
But really, what might help
you is things that we are
working on, which is the
distribution model, which is
how do you take a script and
just let users install it in
their documents and stuff.
JONATHAN RASCHER: Yeah,
do you want to--
AUDIENCE: Can I control the
existing menu of a Google Doc,
like download or print?
If I want to remove
that or disable
that, is that possible?
SAURABH GUPTA: Not today.
You can insert a new
top level menu.
You cannot tinker around with
the existing native menu
options just yet.
JONATHAN RASCHER: Right.
And we've thought about things
like this, but there's some
intricacies involved.
For example, Google Docs can
change their menu structure as
they add features or just as
they move menu items around.
And you wouldn't want your
script to break, for example,
if a Google Docs menu item
wasn't in the location you
expected it to be at.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
is for disabling downloads.
Sometimes you want to share a
folder, and you want people to
only read documents.
And except for PDFs, where
really you can disable
downloads, you can't do that
on most document types.
SAURABH GUPTA: So if I rephrase
your question, you
want more control over whether
a document can be
downloaded or not?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
SAURABH GUPTA: I'm sorry?
SAURABH GUPTA: You cannot
play around with the
existing menu options.
What you can do is if you want
to build an interesting app,
you can add new menu options,
and let users use all of that.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
SAURABH GUPTA: Can you please
come up to the mic?
AUDIENCE: Is this in your
roadmap, controlling the
existing menu items, because we
do a lot of requests from
customers, I can share a
document with someone, but I
don't want them to print
them or download them--
just view it.
SAURABH GUPTA: Yeah.
I mean, you can share
documents with View
privileges, and that's a limited
set of things that you
can do on a document,
and that's about it.
Let's just check online if
there are more questions.
Any questions?
No questions.
Thank you.
JONATHAN RASCHER: Thank
you very much.
[APPLAUSE]